almost everyone has a portable cassette
player these days but how about a
portable VHS player this is the rampage
vbp 1000 an on-the-go VCR and 4-inch
liquid crystal display screen combo
family road trips just got a whole lot
more fun with mountable straps you can
hang the rampage between the driver and
passenger seats so you and the kids can
watch your favorite movie on the go in
awesome VHS quality with tapes that are
built to last
you get great hi-fi sound with the
built-in dual stereo speakers on either
side now with a battery life of up to 50
minutes you can watch almost an entire
TV featurette and when you reach your
destination pack it up put this
fantastically convenient gizmo be
smaller and sleeker perhaps one day but
don't hold your breath let us know in
the comments what your favorite retro
gadgets are and please subscribe to